si monsieur l'arrivée la parole est au
président marc fesneau monsieur le
président madame monsieur le ministre
chers collègues j'ai toujours été contre
la réserve parlementaire c'est un
principe archaïque qui passe l'élu local
ans si tu es heureux de voir quelque
chose c'est un outil électoraliste
inéquitable et coûteux seynod ne sont
pas les miens ces mots sont les mots du
président de l'association nationale dès
maires ruraux de france et donc quand
même
regardons la réalité des choses et
écouter aussi ce que disent les
représentants des maires ruraux de
france voyez c'est pas les miens c'est
ceux du président des maires ruraux on
peut pas dire qu'ils défendent pas les
maires ruraux
deuxième élément deuxième élément 2 ne
vous énervez avoir du talent et son mât
peser un élément s'exprimer
tranquillement je trouve que l'exemple
de monsieur l'arrivée très éclairant est
ce que vous croyez sincèrement que
donner 1900 euros sur un projet de
rénovation thermique qui peut coûter 50
ou 80 millions laissez moi finir
laissez moi finir est ce que vous croyez
sincèrement est de nature à déterminer
la décision d'un conseil municipal
fusse-t-il rural vous plaisantez
j'espère vous plaisantez j'espère le
deuxième chose que je voulais dire sur
ce sujet laissez moi on va y arriver
la deuxième chose que je voulais vous
dire c'est le sentiment collectivement
et je donne je ne fais procès
d'intention à personne désagréable qu'on
l'a vis-à-vis de ce fonds entre d'un
côté les conseillers municipaux les
conseils municipaux qui disent quand les
élections arrivent si on pourrait
demander de la réserve parlementaire et
de députés je trouve ça assez
désagréable d'avoir eu à vivre ça et la
deuxième chose les parlementaires qui
écrivent al homr en disant j'ai obtenu
je vous ai obtenu nous avons réussi à
vous arracher une subvention de 1900
3500 euros pour votre projet deuxième
chose vous dire aussi que j'entendais
monsieur dassault logerot questions
d'actualité c'était un peu si la
ruralité m'était conté c'était le monde
merveilleux d'alice au pays des
merveilles ruralité mais quand même
rappelons les chiffres sur la réserve
parlementaire
la detr c'est un milliard d'euros et la
réserve parlementaire c 130
de la djs et 30 milliards d'euros
monsieur fesneau et donc pour vous
donner les éléments d'échelle sur
lesquels si vous croyez qu'avec la
réserve parlementaire on va sauver la
ruralité je pense qu'on merci beaucoup
monsieur le président merci monsieur
fesneau
[Applaudissements]